انا كنت اود ان يكون هناك كلمه وقف اطلاق
النار ان تكون طرفا او جزءا من القرار
ولكن القرار كما هو لا يمكن ان ينفذ الا
بوقف اطلاق
النار وهناك امر الامر
بايضاح تقرير والمراقبه
ومتابعه تنفيذ هذه الاوامر
اذا هو تقرير خلال شهر
تم
طلبه الولايات
المتحده كون المحكمه قالت نحن اليوم لا
نقرر في جوهر الدعوه وفي نيه الاباده ولكن
نتعامل
مع الاوامر
او الاجراءات
الاحترازيه وهذا القرار يجعل انه ان هناك
امكانيه بانه تم
ارتكاب جريمه اباده جماعيه
وهذا سوف يجعل تلك الدول التي
دعمت اسرائيل والتي هي موقعه هل تعتقد ان
اسرائيل سوف تلتزم بهذه
الاوامر لم اكن
ابدا املوا
ان تلتزم اسرائيل بالقانون ولكن اسرائيل
اصدقاء
اقوياء
يحمونها ما قلناه هو ان هذه
اداه دوليه قضائيه
ل نشرك في النظر في ما يجري في
غزه وما ما قالته المحكمه هو ان
هذه المعاهده معاهده منع الاباده الجماعيه
قد طبقت بالفعل
الان
والان الامم المتحده يمكنها ان تسرع في
العمليه فنحن قد اوجدنا قاعده واساسا
للمجتمع الدولي لكي
يستخدم ارتكاب جرائم لم يعد سهلا مثلما
كان وان هناك
قانونا يقف لها بالمرصد